bon tu es prêt mais ouais ouais ça
recommence ok ok que je pourrais vous
savez pas que johnny et moi on vous
garde 10 ou 20 c
sa collègue race était grosse tare j'ai
une grande nouvelle à t'annoncer ah oui
la kent amy vinh et moi on va avoir un
bébé au génial toutes mes félicitations
marche sur la tête
comment vous comment vous allez c'est ça
le souci il faut qu'on trouve un donneur
de sperme
on pourra voir de gros ennuis que d'un
mètre new york lui c'est vrai qu'il
serait canon le bébé
tom brady de la cnept plus fabuleux de
tous pays et un petit coup de main et
hop dans le gobelet en pollution c'est
quoi ce bordel et embarque pour cent
plus
[ __ ] de tirs une a marqué deux balcons
et dieu merci de me filer un échantillon
on n'est pas amis du tonnerre pour la
vie n'a pas fumé depuis douze jours
entiers je t'ai dit que j'avais touché à
rien ton bébé sa parfaite excuse moi
ainsi que je voudrais pas d'un truc il
faudra nourrir la fourche à 16 ans si on
veut avoir un bébé tu vas devoir prouver
devant un tribunal quand une personne à
part entière pour justin bloque quoi
comme un déchet ou comme une merde et
plus comme un marteau une ligne rouge
c'est qu'un mouvement davies ancêtres 6
et carmaux t en afrique tu lave son
linge dans la rivière les nichons à
lèvres et hop tu te fais en ville et par
tomasz du personnes waouh turon
l'histoire si vivante
jusqu en coiffure dû me prendre un
avocat et obtenir de l'état qu'est que
tu accordes des droits civiques est
votre âge j'ai 26 ans j'ai pas envie
d'avoir un avocat qui chante les
chansons de la reine des neiges à là bas
alors merci nous avoir accordé du temps
mais je crois que ce qu'on va faire
c'est s'asseoir et se mettre au boulot
on a totalement confirmées on sent que
vous avez un gros potentiel
c'est des migraines voulu avoir une
grosse migraine sur le parking dans une
vingtaine de minutes vous êtes à part
pour être reconnu en tant que personne
il faut apporter sa contribution à la
société
ça t'apprendra perdu soir
tu prêtes on leur dit wave asie j'y
crois pas qu'est-ce que tu la valouse de
porno oui je sais je vous l'enverra
peut-être face à une classification
annuler un gus dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre et à contre sens
soit c'est cool de voir la langue
tourner à l'envers à nara que au [ __ ]
mais aussi bob runciman femme soignée et
nlr pas d'un accueil avec des mécanismes